Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello!
Everybody, uh, uh...
Hello.
Welcome to VRChat!
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
I kinda have to talk a little bit fast because we got a show to check out!
If you can see behind me, Sunreal Virtual Festival 2025!
Hello!
Sorry, my chat is, uh, you guys are behind me today.
So, um, uh, oh gosh.
Am I falling through the world?
What's going on?
I don't know.
Ignore any scuff.
What did I just do with my window?
Oh my gosh.
Where did you guys go?
Oh, there you are.
Okay, can you guys hear me?
Can you guys hear me?
Oh wait, hold on.
Can you guys hear me okay?
Can you guys see me?
I'm gonna see.
Yeah?
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay.
So like I said, we got a show to catch.
And I got a lot of things to show you guys.
So, um, first of all, I would like to say thank you Sunreal for sponsoring this stream!
And, uh, Sunreal Virtual Festival 2025!
So, we're gonna go check it out.
Like I said, we got a show to catch first because, um, there's a lot going on in here!
So, I'm gonna, like, take you there.
And then we're gonna run, run, run past some cool stuff.
But I'll show you in a bit.
It's a sneak preview.
And then we're gonna go watch a show.
And then we're gonna walk around and pretend, you know, I've been to real Puroland only once before.
But, it's very, very cute.
And I can promise you that if you think virtual Puroland is cute, you'll really want to, uh, explore real Puroland too.
Because, um, because virtual Puroland is actually based off of real Puroland.
So, um, it's very exciting.
Uh, I just want to say also that, uh, Sunreal Virtual Festival is happening now!
Actually, uh, it's from February 9th to March 9th.
So, uh, we still have a little bit of time.
And you have time to visit virtual Puroland and check out the shows that they got going on.
Um, you can, uh, explore the festival here in VRChat as we are doing today.
Um, they also have things on Spawn, which, you know, is that streaming site you might have used before to watch other shows.
And also a place called MetaMe, which I will explain more about that later.
And they also got some free content on YouTube and reality as well.
So, there's lots of stuff going on.
It's a big ol' party.
Are you guys ready?
Never heard of it?
S-P-W-N.
Spawn.
Yep, that's it.
You guys ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, are you guys ready for our date in virtual Puroland?
Oh my god.
I'm a big fan of Sanrio.
Um, my credentials.
Um, okay.
Let me say my credentials are that I love Cinnamoroll.
Very, very, very much.
Um, you can't see my toes right now, but I'm actually wearing Cinnamoroll, uh, slippers.
At this very moment.
And I own at least, um, five pairs, five different pairs of Cinnamoroll socks.
And I have Cinnamoroll clothes, and Cinnamoroll underwear, and Cinnamoroll plushies.
And my desk mat is Cinnamoroll.
And I have Cinnamoroll ears.
And I, and he's not a dog, he's, I mean, sorry, wait, he's not a bunny, he's a dog.
Oh gosh, I almost mixed it up.
Wait, what time is it?
We got five minutes.
Oh my god, five minutes until the show.
Wait, where are you guys going?
Why is my chat disappearing?
Hold on.
Everything's weird right now.
Hold on, I'm gonna, I'm gonna pop you guys out so I can read you.
Not on.
There we go.
I have you guys in here now.
I have you guys here now.
I don't want you guys not on...
My computer.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's me.
That's you!
So close.
I'm getting closer.
Oh yeah!
And also, I wanted to say...
So, a little bit of...
A little bit of...
What's the word?
Some details about Sanrio Virtual Festival.
The virtual event is set in a massive virtual space modeled after...
Featuring artists, creators, Sanrio characters.
Everybody.
Sanrio fans can all enjoy and all have a good time.
What the heck?
Where did my notes go?
Why is everything so cursed today?
Sorry guys, hold on.
Hey boo.
There we go.
Anyway.
So, you can go, you can interact.
Of course, there's gonna be other people.
You can also have some...
You can also meet some of the other Sanrio characters.
And, you know, just have a good, immersive, fun time in Virtual Puroland.
And...
Yeah!
Let's go check it out.
One moment, please.
I'm actually going to try and do something.
There we go.
One moment.
I actually want to see if we can get into our own private space real quick.
If not, just ignore the other people.
Ignore the people in the world.
You know what?
Let's just go.
We'll see whatever...
Let's see who else is around.
You know?
It's a surprise.
We'll see.
Yeah, ignore the people.
I'll turn them down.
We won't be able to hear them.
We won't listen to them.
Okay.
Let's go!
As you can see...
As you can see, too...
You can enter right through the main...
The main VR chat portal.
So...
Very, very cool.
It's loading.
You guys see a black screen?
Okay.
Let me make sure all my audio is good.
Being in VR is hard, but it makes it so much more worth it.
You guys hear anything?
Can you guys hear anything?
Turning off my mic.
Nobody can hear me.
I'm scared.
You see Kaiju in the background?
There's gonna be like all sorts of people.
We can hear music?
You can?
Okay, good, good, good.
Good, good, good.
I don't know where my audio went, but...
You hear music?
Okay, good, good, good.
Okay, alright.
Sorry, I'm not gonna be talking for a bit.
I'm gonna look really awkward.
People are gonna see me and be like...
What is she doing?
So weird.
Alright.
Alright, let's go to the show.
But I can't show you this yet, yet, yet.
We gotta go to the show.
What is going on?
You can't...
Spoilers.
We're coming back.
We're coming back here.
Spoilers.
Running, running, running to the show.
Or we're gonna be late.
No, we're not gonna be late.
We're gonna make it to the show.
I'm going down the stairs.
We're going to the show.
Alright, guys.
Let's go watch...
Dream in a Dream.
Yeah, don't look.
Don't look yet.
Don't look, don't look yet.
It's all...
It's all spoilers.
Wait.
I think the show is starting.
You guys...
Let me...
Let me set you up.
Hold on.
It's looking at me.
So cute.
Wait, hold on.
Let me...
Where did you guys go?
There you are.
Let me adjust a bit.
Let's move it like right here.
Okay.
Give me one second.
As long as you guys can hear, it's okay.
I currently can't hear.
So I'm gonna be adjusting a few things.
We can hear?
Okay, good, good, good.
That's more important for you guys to hear.
But I will soon hear.
I'm working on it.
VRChat has been giving...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Wait, this looks exactly...
Oh my gosh.
Exactly like where they have the parade and everything.
Hold on.
I'm gonna...
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna be in your shot, but...
Where are you guys?
Oh, there you are.
I don't wanna be in your shot.
I don't wanna be blocking anybody else either.
Shit, I'm bright.
I'm so bright.
I'm shining.
I'm gonna move.
Hold on, I'm trying to fix my audio.
Turn your phone by this time.
Look how cute he is!
Like a ghost.
One moment, everybody.
As long as you're watching.
Watch, watch, watch.
Get out of the way.
It's so pretty.
Oh my gosh.
It seriously looks exactly how it does in real Puroland.
And it's really fun because they do parades here and they do shows here.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Wait, where are you guys?
Come back, camera!
Oh my gosh!
Here, I'll let you guys do it like this.
Oh, we're back.
Kitty!
Where did you guys go?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, look how cute she is!
Oh,
she went to the bathroom!
Oh my gosh.
Magical door?
Is the audio okay by the way?
Please let me know.
Yeah, it's good?
Okay, good, good.
I'm gonna do something real quick.
Okay.
Let me know if it does.
If you hear a double.
Wait!
Can you guys see?
Wait, I'm gonna redo the camera.
Hold on.
Where are you guys?
I can't see.
Oh no!
Wait, I'm gonna send you guys to my view.
Can you guys see?
Oh my god!
No!
Where are you guys?
This is all over the place!
This is craziness!
I think you guys are down here.
I got you.
All
over the place!
This is...
This is truly something I feel you must experience.
Here, I'll go on this side.
We can be watching together, okay guys?
I said I won!
Oh my gosh!
Daniel!
Pompompurin!
Come on!
So cute!
It's so cute!
Look at them go!
Everything is so beautiful!
I wanna just run up to them and...
You know?
I just wanna hug them tightly.
It's cool, isn't it?
No, I'm not sponsored.
I'm good today.
I'm good.
I'm not in a sponsored stream.
I'm being on my best behavior.
Cinnamoroll!
They're floating!
We're floating!
Wait, can we go to Cinnamoroll's side?
You guys?
There you guys go.
Look out!
Oh my gosh!
Just a little guy!
Wow!
Can I show you guys real quick the area too?
Look at the world.
Oh, hi Robert.
Bye!
Oh my gosh!
Daniel!
It's
so cute!
Cute!
Oh my gosh, the pen light on her thing is so fun.
Pompompurin!
Pompompurin.
That's one of Matara's favorites.
She likes Pompompurin and...
I can't remember their names.
Oh no, look at their faces!
They're too cute!
Even Kuromi!
So cute.
The one that looks like Fishman.
I don't know why I can't remember his name all of a sudden.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
In VR guys, this is kind of intense.
Wait, they're flying above me!
What's happening?
They're all...
They're flying!
Oh no.
Guys,
I apologize so much again also.
I currently don't have audio, so I wish I could try to translate some of the Japanese for you guys, but...
I'm currently just going off of vibes.
Because something's up with my headset, but the show goes on.
And I'm really enjoying myself regardless.
So hopefully you guys are hearing all the audio.
It's very cute and fun.
You hearing it is more important than me.
Flabs are good.
Look how cute he is!
Pompompurin.
Oh my gosh!
This looks so awesome!
Oh my gosh, it's giving like Madomagi vibes.
It's so cool!
I'll show you guys a little bit of the whole setting.
Look how cool this is.
Oh!
Cinnamon!
Kuromi!
Kuromi.
He's 2D.
They're 2D.
They're just like me.
Well, I'm 3D right now.
Oh my gosh!
They're on a stage!
Oh my god.
Oh, this place!
Guys,
I 100%...
If you have a VR headset...
Experience this in VR.
How is this free?
It's so cool.
Be careful, Pudding!
No!
No, Pudding!
Get up!
You can do it!
Look at Cinnamon.
Look at his face.
Hey, Cinnamon!
Final boss time.
No, they look so sad!
Oh, someone's translating in the chat.
Thank you so much.
Sick tunes.
I believe it.
I'm gonna have to watch it again later.
I'm gonna come back.
There's actually several shows throughout the day.
You can come and see.
Kiwi looks so determined.
You got this!
The design is so cool, yeah.
I'm so boring.
No!
Oh no!
All the negative comments!
They're flying around us!
He's like, right above me.
Don't let the negative comments get to you!
No...
Pudding!
Oh, the mic.
The mic!
She's over here now.
Oh my god!
He's sucking them up!
No!
Look at Kitty Jenkins!
Hold on.
Oh my goodness.
You guys can't see.
I think she just saved them.
She just stopped them with love.
There you go.
They're all floating.
Get you guys in close to the action.
Cute!
Oh my gosh, the visual effects go hard.
They go so crazy!
It feels like I'm watching a music video.
What the heck?
Oh my god!
The stage is even down there.
You can see it.
This is going so hard.
Something broke up there.
Wait, the parrot's back!
Did they say to send your energy?
That's so cute!
Look at everybody's...
Everybody's sending the energy!
That's so cute!
Look at them go!
Cute!
Send your dreams!
Thank you!
I think someone's
trying to give me a pen light.
Thank you!
There we go, I got one too!
I don't know how to use this.
Yay!
Sorry, I didn't realize I was sending so many.
Aww, they are getting along.
In front of Pompompurin's body.
Awaken Pompompurin!
Oh, sorry.
He's back!
I'm shocked.
They are so cute!
The world is so cute, this one too.
The little jellyfish in the air.
So cute!
Kitty...
Thank you for letting me realize my dream.
I'm glad.
Remember this wonderful dream.
The world is so small!
Look how small he is!
Everybody else is so tiny!
So tiny...
Look at him.
Oh, he's on his shield.
He's just a little guy.
I want to go squeeze him.
Oh, the bird!
Get in the ground where you belong!
So, so cute.
Pompompurin's little butt.
See it?
Cinema!
I don't know if you noticed the person over there too.
On the other side of the map.
You can see the whole...
You can see the show from wherever you want to stand.
Definitely come check it out, you know?
The tree!
The tree is coming back!
Oh my god!
What is the guy kitty's name?
His name is Daniel.
He's kitty's boyfriend.
It's manifesting.
I feel like I've
had a lot of wonderful dreams.
Meow!
It's so cute!
But why?
Why?
I'm going to make apple pie, so everyone come!
You can see her bathroom over there.
Bedroom over there.
That is too cute.
I want to know what the other shows are like now.
And this show actually has no subtitles.
As you can tell, it's in Nihongo, but no subtitles.
But there are other shows that do have English subtitles.
The visuals alone are very very cool.
But there are also some shows with English subtitles.
I'm sorry, I wish I could translate for you guys.
I still can't hear it.
Can you understand what they're saying?
Maybe if I could hear the show, but I've been in silence this entire time.
You get the gist?
Good good.
Luckily, Sanrio is for children, so it's not too difficult, right?
It's easy Japanese.
Wait, are we taking a picture?
I want
to be in the picture.
Come on, Daniel.
Oh.
Just kidding.
He absorbed it.
Here, let's go.
Let's go over here, you guys.
Let's talk over here.
Wait, can I?
Maybe not.
Here, we'll talk right here.
Oh gosh.
Like, right here.
Wait, hold on.
Oh gosh, you guys are all the way up there.
Can I grab?
How do I let go?
One moment, sorry.
Sorry, don't get dizzy.
Don't get dizzy on me.
Yay, I have people.
Hello!
I have people trying to talk to me, but I have no voices on.
Yay!
Did you guys like the show?
Sorry, I have no mouth moving.
Maybe I can change into my other avatar then.
If I'm not going to have my mouth moving anyway.
Give me a second.
We change.
What just happened?
Hold on.
One moment.
Let's just become bigger.
Become bigger.
There we go.
Yay!
That was so cute!
Oh my gosh, that show was so crazy though, because...
Oh my gosh, hello!
As you can see, you can come into the world and there will be lots of other people you can meet.
So, you know, even if you're just like, I don't have anyone who plays VRChat or anything.
You can always come and you can always, you know, maybe make a Wisp hangout to come and see some of the other shows.
At the... at the... at the Virtual Player Land, you know?
But that's not the only thing I wanted to show you guys today.
There's other stuff.
If you thought that was it, no, no, no.
There's more to see.
Yo, yo, yo.
And...
So, before we go on to the next thing, I want to...
I want to go back to the beginning, because I said, remember, there was like some stuff that I said spoilers, spoilers, spoilers about.
So let's go to... yeah.
Okay, hold on.
Let's... I think if I press respawn, it'll work.
Let's try it out.
Respawn!
Wait!
You guys are all the way over there!
Give me a second.
Actually, let me try doing this.
You guys see a black screen right now?
You guys see anything right now?
What do you see right now?
You guys have created...
Oh, sorry, hold on.
One moment, please.
I have created a very own world!
So we are now...
I wanted to show off how, you know, you could hang out with other people.
And it was kind of fun.
It was really fun seeing everybody cheer on during the show, right?
So, kind of glad that we got that experience.
But welcome to the main entrance of Sanrio Borderland!
Which, this is kind of insane, because it looks the exact same!
It looks the exact same of how it is in the actual, real Borderland.
Yeah, the pen light was so cool, right?
And it was so nice that someone gave me one.
But, let's do a couple of fun things that are on the main strip here.
So look, like I said earlier, you can select a language.
You can change to Nihongo or English, which I think is pretty nice.
And the visual, the key visual is so cute!
Look how cute the character is!
So cute.
I love interactive shows.
Me too, me too!
So let's go check out this part!
Oh my gosh.
You guys.
I have to show you this.
This, I was wanting, like, to do.
I was wanting to do this since we first got here.
Because I did this earlier, actually.
Do you see?
Do you see?!
Oh!
How cute!
Oh, and look, they have a bunch of other...
Oh, it's kind of blocking it.
If I click remove...
Am I still wearing them?
No!
I'm not still wearing them!
But look, you can get Kuromi!
You can get My Melody!
You can get Hello Kitty!
You can... What is that?
Little Twin Stars?
I think?
But we'll go back to...
Go back to...
To Cinnamoroll, of course.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So cute, right?!
And then you can adjust it!
And, like, make it fit exactly to your head!
Wait, why aren't my legs working?
One moment.
Don't look.
Don't look!
Why aren't my legs working?
Maybe now?
Oh, sorry guys, I just realized my legs haven't been working.
That's strange.
I'm having all sorts of scuff today, so I'm really... I apologize.
But I hope that you guys are having fun, regardless.
Okay, let's keep going.
Oh, sorry, I just left without you guys.
Okay.
Look, it's so cute!
They have little photo areas...
That you can take pictures in.
My legs are even all kind of wonky.
What's going on?!
My legs, you can take pictures!
And, actually, hold on.
I gotta get my notes real quick.
I gotta get my notes.
There is a... there's a couple!
So, if you know...
If you know...
Puroland!
There's rides at Puroland.
So it means there's also rides at Virtual Puroland.
And one of them that we'll try and go on is the My Melody and Kuromi.
It's like a rhythm game?
Maybe less of a ride.
But...
It's extra special because...
Did you guys know?
That this year is My Melody's 50th anniversary?
And Kuromi's 20th anniversary?
I... I...
How?
50th!
I can't even believe that.
Like, that's actually so crazy.
But yeah, so I'm gonna...
We're gonna try that out.
There's also a boat ride we can go on.
But first...
I'm maybe getting a little bit ahead of myself.
Maybe...
Let's explore.
Let's have a good time.
Do you guys recognize?
Do you guys rec...
Wait, what is this?
Konohama...
Chara...
Pa...
Sorry, my thing is...
Chara Paki...
Pakio...
Wait...
Sorry, my...
It's like...
Freaking out.
Saigo...
Wait...
Do I...
Where do I do it?
It's a gashapon?
How do I do it?
Where?
Look at him!
Look how sad he is.
Chara Paki...
Chocolate...
Oh, they're selling a nation...
It's like an actual chocolate they're selling.
So these are actually all sponsors.
So...
Oh, I wanna try.
I'm gonna be in Japan next week.
I'm gonna be on the lookout for it.
Because look at this little pen.
Is it like a...
Cookie kind of chocolate.
Blueberry flavor.
Oh, each...
Each individual part.
So like the purple is a...
Wait, sorry, sorry.
The purple is like the blueberry flavor.
And then the pink parts are the...
Are the strawberry flavor.
And then...
Oh, like a puff chocolate.
And then white chocolate.
Wow.
And then look at this.
You can like break it apart.
And then you have your own...
That's what it is.
The Chara Paki.
So you can break it apart.
Oh my gosh, what is this?
I've played these games before.
Wait, I was doing it.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
You're right.
Oh
my gosh, so cute.
Wait, hold on.
Let me...
Let me put you guys like right here.
There we go.
Okay, we'll do my mellow too.
Oh, you guys too.
Where are you?
Bug, bug, bug, bug, bug.
Okay.
Ouch.
Don't say ouch.
Let's keep going.
So yeah, do you recognize?
Of course you do.
There we go.
It's Famipmart!
And look, you have Famipay.
Hi Famipay!
Wait, use?
How?
Do you want to change your avatar?
Do I become him?
I'm Famipay!
What?
I'm 2D.
I'm flat!
I'm flat Famipay!
Help me!
Oh my hand!
I've returned to 2D.
Sometimes I can see myself behind me.
I thought I was gonna become you.
Okay, let me change.
Let me change back.
But, hold on, let me show you guys too.
It's fun, it's fun, it's fun.
Oh, it's fun, it's fun.
Over here?
Where are you guys?
I lost you again.
Oh, hello.
Over here?
You see that?
Is anybody hungry?
We got Famitiki!
Famitiki!
Real Famitiki!
Look!
Can I...
Can I eat it?
I'm gonna put it back real nicely.
Oh, we have...
We have Famipay Hello Kitty.
Famipay.
Hello Kitty Bear.
And then, also, look at this.
You guys know Chiki?
These... This is so cool, actually.
These actually work.
Where are you guys?
There you are.
Oh, wait, hold on.
So these...
These work.
Ready?
Say cheese!
Did it work?
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna see your beautiful selves.
See your beautiful selves.
There you are.
Your eyes were closed.
Oh, wait.
OK, let me...
You're a ghost!
It's my... This is my treasure.
It's our time at Puroland together.
It's my treasure.
My treasure Polaroid.
Do you wanna Chiki with me?
Do you wanna get a Polaroid from an actual Instax camera with me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, shut up.
Shut up.
OK, where did it go?
There it is.
OK.
We're taking a selfie.
Cheese!
Wait, hold on.
Can I get my fingers to work?
I'll just do doya.
Doya!
Cheese!
Let's see how it looks, let's see how it looks.
OK.
I'm a professional Chiki taker.
Wait.
You guys, this might be actually the best photo.
Look at this.
Look at...
It takes over, sorry.
That's kind of cool.
Wait, it takes over the thing.
Look at that.
Look how I got the Sanrio Puroland perfectly in the background.
How am I such a professional?
I told you I'm a professional.
I told you.
That might be the best picture ever taken.
Ever.
Fullscreen jumpscare.
Sorry.
That might be the best ever.
That might be the best ever do it.
I don't know.
I'm a natural.
But yeah, come and get your own Chikis as well.
Here at Puroland.
You can save that one.
Save that one.
Wait, hold on.
There you go.
Save it.
Sanrio Virtual Festival 2035.
Print screen.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me...
I'm actually going to print screen.
I'm actually going to get rid of Chat.
I want it for myself.
Goodbye Chat.
Print screen.
And screenshot.
Okay, you guys are welcome back now.
Perfect.
There we go.
I'm the best ever do it.
And save.
Yay!
Alright.
Let me look at my notes once again.
I don't want to forget anything.
So...
Let's go on the boat ride.
And maybe see if we can try the...
Wait, will I be able to do the rhythm game?
I can't hear anything.
Maybe you guys will have to come and try it instead.
We can go on the boat ride because it's also modeled off of the actual boat ride at real Pudoland.
But it's been recreated and upgraded for the virtual festival.
So, let's try it out.
Right, right, right?
Let's check it out, check it out, check it out.
And then...
Um...
Yeah.
Oh!
Of course, you know, there's other stuff in the main area around here as well.
So...
One moment.
My...
There we go.
Alright.
See, look how cute this is!
Nyantasia!
You have this, which is like avatar fashion.
If you're...
Whoa!
If you're like really into styling your VRChat avatar, they got like specific...
They have specific clothes.
Sunrio clothes for...
Oh, you know what I just noticed?
I would have been perfect with my headband, huh?
Dang.
I love it!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
And then...
Kuromi.
Kuromi, Kuromi.
Wait.
Cheese.
Cheese, cheese, cheese.
Ow!
Sorry about my legs, don't look at them.
Cheese.
Good job.
Kuromi hearts!
Kuromi.
Alright.
Let's go, go.
Let's go, go inside.
Oh yeah, and then here you can actually get real headbands.
You can get the headbands.
Alright.
Whoa!
Welcome!
Sunrio Virtual Festival 2035 is a virtual event set in a vast space within virtual Sunrio Puroland!
Featuring virtual artists, virtual creators, and Sunrio characters.
It's a new kind of world-class virtual festival where Sunrio fans and virtual experts alike can enjoy communicating with each other!
Yeah.
Let's go inside.
This also looks exactly like the real entrance to Puroland.
To the real Puroland.
So they did a kind of crazy amazing job of recreating it.
Welcome, welcome officially!
Alright.
Let's go find that boat ride.
I'll take you on a journey.
So, from what I can remember...
Oh look, there's like a jukebox here.
From what I can remember...
Oh yeah, this is another thing!
Pochacco's Nom Nom Party!
I think this is also another show.
There's also... there's like different floors.
But from what I can remember...
Upstairs...
Like on that side of real Puroland is like restaurants and gift shops.
Then there's more restaurants on that side upstairs.
But we're going downstairs.
Virtual boat ride!
That should be it.
I though...
Look, there's also the parade.
You can come and see the parade too.
There's also the Virtual Puro Village.
The Ryugu... Ryugu Castle.
Oh, this is the... this is the...
This is the...
The rhythm game.
So, I'm going to do a not public boat ride though.
Give me one moment.
So that we can enjoy our boat ride in peace.
Perhaps.
Okay.
We're entering the boat ride!
So, I really love Cinnamoroll, obviously, as you could see from before.
But I also...
Oops, sorry, my bad.
I also really love Hanamaru Obake.
So, if we see him...
I mean, he's a ghost, so it's kind of my thing.
Anyway, let's go.
Oh, cute!
Sanrio characters.
Boat ride!
And this one is all of...
So basically, in this one, Cinnamoroll receives an invitation from Kitty.
From Hello Kitty, so...
Look!
There's Kero-P!
And Batsumaru!
Pochacco!
I can't remember the duck's name.
Little Twin Stars!
What's the duck's name?
Spoilers.
It's not spoilers.
You're going to hear it.
It literally says it right here!
One day Cinnamon got...
Hold on, my headset.
My headset.
So...
My headset's been kind of like...
The entire time, so I apologize.
It's been a little funky.
The VR... I really wanted the VR to happen, so I was just like...
I'm going to make it happen, but...
It's been a toughy one.
Oh, here we go.
Here, I'll just zoom in so you guys can read it too.
One day, Cinnamon got a party invitation from Hello Kitty.
Let's all go on an adventure with Cinnamon on a boat.
Use the boat's...
Oh, the Kirameki stick to help the Sanrio characters as you head to the party.
Snap a commemorative photo during the boat ride too.
Yay!
Okay, that's actually how it is at the real Puroland too.
You get to snap your own photo.
Oh look, look, look!
Let's board the boat.
Click on a chair and sit on the boat.
Four people can ride.
Okay.
Look at the giant pancake.
Alright, where's the boat?
Over here?
Departure!
Okay.
I'm kind of nervous.
Do you think there will be a drop?
Oh.
You're Avatar!
Avatar!
What?
0.8 meters?
1.5 meters?
Look at my face.
Do I look...
Do you think I'll be okay?
I must be so small for the ride.
Look, I look so chill with the way my...
My legs are messed up today.
I don't know quite why.
Okay, maybe let's just try it.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna sit in the back.
Wait!
Oh no!
I'm not ready!
Okay, alright.
I'm gonna sit in the back.
I'm sitting.
I'm gonna...
Wait.
There we go.
Okay.
You guys should be able to see now too.
Start!
Wait!
I can't reach it!
Start!
Wait.
I might have to...
Let me get out of the boat.
Where are you guys anyway?
Sit.
Okay.
Once everyone is ready, press the start button.
Are you guys ready?
Start!
Oh!
Cinnamon bun!
Sorry.
Oh, that's my head.
I'm following you guys all around.
That's kinda why I wanted to sit in the back.
Let's go!
This is so crazy for me.
Original ride!
Sick trick!
I love the virtual world.
Me too!
Guys, unfortunately this is how I really sound like on rides.
I'm screaming at everything.
Oh!
Cinnamon is over here.
Look at me!
Look at the lighting!
Look at my hair!
You can see his hair!
He's so cute!
I look really mean too.
Wow!
What is this?
Bumblebee!
Wow!
Cute!
I wish I could show you guys everything.
He's bouncing everywhere!
I wish there was like a...
Let me see if there is like a...
Where am I?
Oh, what the heck just happened?
You guys...
Why are you in a ball?
I apologize for all the scuff you guys.
Makes it authentic.
Like little tin sours and me.
Yeah!
Where is Cinnamon?
Oh there he is up there.
He's over there.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
This world...
Wow!
There is so much going on.
Oh Kuromi!
My mellow!
Oh my god, they are so close.
Wait, I have a stick here.
Also, I didn't even show you guys.
There is subtitles down here.
It's not showing up on the camera for some reason.
But there is subtitles.
So if you are just like...
I can't understand Nihongo!
You have to come back and watch the round yourself!
Because there are subtitles.
Look, I'm shooting!
I'm the popcorn!
I'm shooting, I'm shooting.
Hold on.
Thank you!
I'll read the subtitles.
Let's all take a picture!
Remember this moment!
Cheese!
Oh, the camera is over here!
I wonder what it's going to look like.
Wait, I'm so curious.
What is this going to look like?
We are back into the rainbow portal.
There are so many things to...
There you guys are.
Alright!
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Yay!
That was kind of chaotic, wasn't it?
That was kind of chaotic.
But yay!
It was a short little ride.
Definitely come back yourself and experience the real thing.
Let's see.
Play with me again?
Thank you!
Thanks for saving me from my Melody and Kuromi.
So cute!
I want to see her picture.
I want to see her picture real bad.
Saving her from the popcorn.
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Look how cute!
I'm sitting in the boat!
Stop!
It's too cute!
Wait, hold on.
I need to screenshot this again.
Hold on guys.
Oh, sorry.
Don't look.
I know you can see me.
Wait, I'm trying to find my computer.
Wait, where's my mouse?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, now I...
Get rid of you guys.
Goodbye.
And then...
Okay.
How do I do this?
No!
Keep it there.
How do I do it?
Where are you guys anyway?
Wait.
Download.
Touch your camera.
Oh, I can download it here.
Oh, maybe...
You guys will take it for me, right?
You guys will just keep it for me?
Hold on.
I think I need to move you guys.
Come here.
I'll grab you.
Okay.
There we go.
And...
Screenshot.
Okay, you guys can go back now.
Yay!
Alrighty.
Oh my gosh, that picture mode is so cute though!
Did you get it?
I got it.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Let's head back.
Let's head back somewhere to talk.
Donuts.
Pancake.
Oh, that's the departure.
Oh, we came from this side.
That's right.
Mm-mm, mm-mm.
I think we might actually have to go back from...
I think, yeah.
Let me make a new instance.
We have to go back through the world world.
So, I only even got to show you guys just a tiny little bit of things that...
That...
Sunrayo Virtual Festival has.
So...
You know, like I said, there's other...
There's the parade, there's other shows.
There is a schedule, so you'll wanna, like, you know...
You'll wanna check it.
Links and everything, all that fun stuff...
Is in...
The description!
In the description!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me get my notes one more time because there is one last thing, of course, to talk about when it comes to the festival.
Which I did mention that there's more performances and all that fun stuff.
And the creators, because there's actually artist performances as well as all the fun free things we did here.
Just to...
You guys...
You do know that VRChat is free, right?
VRChat is free!
So all of this that you can see and explore in here is all free.
But if you want more specialized, cool, and exciting performances...
There are the artist performances as well!
And there's a total of 30 groups of artists that have been performing and...
And are performing...
Have performed...
Actually, I think there's some happening, like, right now.
It's kind of crazy.
It's including Vtubers, Vsingers, anime characters, celebrities, and other VR creators.
So, you might recognize some of the names such as K-Sun, or IronMouse, or Moona...
Yeah!
Tsukino Mito!
There's a lot of very cool artists, so...
That are performing.
Oh, you might have heard of Aqua from Love Live!
Yeah!
So there are a variety of tickets and ways to watch the artist performances, so...
You can use a VR headset, like how I am right now.
You can use your computer or your phone.
And the prices kind of vary depending on what kind of ticket you get.
So we have a standard pass, which is for Quest and Android.
It's 880 yen.
You can watch three streams.
We have the standard pass for a VR headset, so you can watch the performances in VR.
Which is kind of crazy.
Which is 8,800 yen.
Including a VR greeting, which is very cool.
And also a standard pass, but with support goods.
Similar to the other one, but it has the support goods, which is 12,100 yen.
But there's also the spawn pass, which is the streaming site I mentioned earlier.
Which is 4,400 yen.
It's not VR, but you can watch some of the performances on your computer.
As well as MetaMe, which is the MetaMe pass, which is 1,580 yen.
Or rather, equivalent to that, or 3,500 yen equivalent-ish.
But if you're like, what is MetaMe?
I've never heard of that before.
It is developed by NTT DoCoMo, which is the phone company, if you've heard of it.
It's insanely famous in Japan.
But MetaMe is a 3D stage that allows for multi-angle streaming.
So you can see from different angles.
And also, this is really cool actually, live effects based on fan interactions.
Basically, you can kind of create the effects that happen during the show.
Which is very, very neat, I think.
And so yeah, like I mentioned earlier, some of the featured artists for MetaMe are...
Moona from Hololive ID.
Pmaru-sama, which you guys might have heard her before.
And a few others, of course.
V for Mirai is one of them.
So if you'd like a more immersive experience watching the shows, check out the Sunrio Virtual Festival on MetaMe.
And tickets can be purchased online.
Links in the description.
To get the ticket, you'll have to use MetaMe's internal currency called Metamo.
That's why I was saying the MetaMe pass is like 1580 equivalent.
Because you're purchasing the Metamo currency.
But if you have any questions, they have an FAQ page.
So you can check it out.
Yeah, V for Mirai is tonight.
I think Kei-san was also tonight, or Moona.
Like I said, the festival is until March 9th.
So you still have some time.
Definitely check out the schedule to see when the different free performances are here.
Because like I said, if you want to see the one that we just saw again, too.
The one that we just saw with probably a better view than what I gave you.
Then you can come and watch it for free.
Just make sure you find what time it is on the schedule.
Because it's not like you can just hop into the world and go watch it.
It's kind of on a... It's like a real schedule.
Like you're actually going to the park, you know?
But virtually!
And the parade and all that fun stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be sure to come check it out.
If you're interested in some of the other live performances by the creators, grab a ticket.
Don't miss out, don't miss out.
I hope you guys enjoyed checking out Puroland with me!
Like I kind of mentioned before, I've only been to the real Puroland just one time before.
But it was so fun!
I actually went with Doki.
A long while ago.
What is that?
I think my cat is rebelling against me.
No?
Something just moved in my room.
It's haunting.
By me.
But yeah!
Pies is in here actually.
She's been just chilling on my chair.
But I hope you enjoyed!
I hope you guys had fun!
And I will see you guys next time!
Check out the festival!
Thank you again...
To... thank you again... Sanrio... Sanrio Festival.
Thank you Virtual Sanrio Festival for the sponsor.
And I hope you guys have a good day!
Have a good night!
Thank you!
See you!
Bye bye!
Wait... wait... one second...
One second...
One second!
One second, one second, one second...
One second, one second.
Oh no!
I lost him!
Anyway, well, I have this at least.
Bye bye!
Thank you!
I was gonna wear the ears.
Bye bye!
Get inside my brain!
Wait, where's my mouse?
Um, hold on.
I'll end the stream when I can find it.
Okay.
Bye!
Oh, I lost it again.
Wait, this is so awkward.
Guys, I don't know where I'm clicking.
I can't see anything.
Oh, wait a second.
Where's my mouse?
I give up.
There it is.
Okay, bye bye!